look what is your advice for young
comedians who are trying to break into
the Hollywood land okay okay right this
is my life that's a secret okay I'm
listening they give yourself as an
octopus this is this is real here's
Elizabeth you're not okay and you have
eight arms and if all eight arms aren't
out hoping to like suction on to
something then you're not using all your
eight arms alright so that means like do
everything you can generate content
there is no stage that you should not
feel like you should be on there's no
medium that you feel that you should
feel is beneath you just like be out
there all your little eight tentacles be
enough and Thomas is definitely a
figurative octopus from his nearly
constant string of improv shows web
series hbo's silicon valley and in
theaters now lebron was really about
like that small-town celebrity and are
you like G is your town a small town it
is and I wasn't a celebrity when I came
back you weren't yeah Nelson British
Columbia I was expecting a goddamn
ticker tape parade the mayor to give me
the key to the city and nothing don't
even give it gave a crap